chez denoël et puis enfin françoise
giroud dont il faut rappeler quand même
dans cette émission que vous avez été
ministre
6 et puis journaliste écrivain et alors
cette fois vous mais pas pour un essai
pas pour un livre de souvenirs mais pour
un roman c'est à dire votre premier
roman aux éditions mazarine le bon
plaisir je me suis demandé si vous aviez
choisi la fiction parce que vous ne
pouviez pas parce que c'était un bon
moyen de dire des choses notamment sur
le pouvoir que ne pourriez peut-être pas
dire autrement c'est pas beaucoup de
choses que je me suis privé de dire sur
le pouvoir autrement je vais pas
terrible en travaux pas soyons n'ai pas
besoin de me réfugier derrière la
fiction vraiment pas non donc c'est
comme ça un groupe comme ça pour le
roman mais c'est autre chose la vérité
romanesque
ça permet de dire un certain nombre de
choses qui ne sont pas des faits crainte
est très empruntée à telle ou telle
personne mais de reconstituer des
personnes après tout c'est toujours
comme ça que les romanciers ont
travaillé non alors autrement c'est
l'histoire d'une bombe à retardement à
savoir une lettre qui courent paris et
qu'il faut désamorcer
voilà exactement alors on peut le lire
avec un oeil au rec 2 yeux vient de voir
des collages de prévert ou simplement
parfois lille on sait rien par là qu'on
peut lire ce livre avec un oeil et il
voit en effet une histoire qui monte un
peu comme une histoire policière en tout
cas avec bon il s'aventure et des
rebondissements c'est ça un peu parfois
série noire un peu oui je prends ça
plutôt pour un compliment mais ce n'est
pas facile
donc c'est une histoire d' aventure très
tendu c'est exactement ce que les
américains n'y a pas de mots je crois en
français pour le dire appelle un pitch
turner a livre dont on est obligé de
tourner la page
jusqu'au bout voilà enfin j'espère c'est
avec un délit
et puis deux yeux alors avec les deux si
on les lit avec les deux yeux il ya en
dessous
disons un petit conte philosophique
enfin libre
désiré de moeurs sur le pouvoir ce n'est
pas seulement sur le pouvoir d'ailleurs
parce que sur le pouvoir politique dans
le cas parce que c'est un milieu que je
connais bien mais le héros qui est dans
le livre le président de la république
aurait pu être par exemple un grand
patron c'est sûr mais je veux dire c'est
cesser le pouvoir c'est à dire les
hommes de pouvoir
alors pour bien qu'on comprenne juste
dire un tout petit peu de l'histoire
c'est au fond c'est l'histoire d'une led
c'est à dire un homme politique qui va
au japon qui envoie une lettre à sa
jeune maîtresse à laquelle il lui dit
écoute l'enfant que tu attends qui est
le mien je n'en veux surtout pas
débrouille toi et puis quelques années
après c'est un politique est devenu
président de la république
la femme sa maîtresse il n'a plus aucun
contact avec elle simplement on apprend
qu'elle a gardé cet enfant et puis elle
a gardé aussi malheureusement une lettre
cette fameuse lettre on la lui dérobe et
elle tombe dans des mains évidemment
douteuses et s'ouvre à tout le monde se
met à la recherche de cette lettre le
président la république qui s'appelle
caster
le ministre de l'intérieur qui s'appelle
pollux et puis évidemment d'autres
personnages de l'air bon alors le ski
ski j'ai envie de dire quand même que
c'est un roman je sais pas sur la
solitude du pouvoir vous employez ça sur
la fragilité du pouvoir
moi j'ai envie d'aider aussi sont
l'intolérance du pouvoir oui c'est à
dire que c'est un repos où on voit un
jeune homme un peu naïf et candide et
des listes qui s'en va tirer les
moustaches si je puis dire des sommes
qu'ils ôtent au pouvoir et déjà pouvoir
ça devient très méchant c'est implacable
sans défaut leveaux waridon il faut
qu'ils le gardent s'ils sont menacés et
sensuelle plus on est cruel quand il se
sent menacée mais là ils ont des moyens
peut être un peu plus grand que les
autres
donc c'est ce choc
qui vous donne ce sentiment peut-être
d'intolérance non ils sont pas
spécialement être les rangs sont pas
spécialement à talairan peu plus que
d'autres se sent menacé
votre caster président la république et
donc je veux dire qu'il ressemble à
aucun autre président de la république
monsieur kanak vous qui avez connu pas
mal de président la république tout va
aller travailler ensemble sauf bon vous
dites quand même ceci vous dit ceci à
propos de caster personne ne pouvait
plus songé à lui parler à lui dire autre
chose que ce qu'ils voulaient entendre
sauf à se faire éjecter ou rejeter dans
le camp des conspirateurs des conjurés
des comploteurs ça c'est un fait et des
danses ya fin de mandat général a enfin
demandé au début son temps comme ça j'ai
pu observer et ça je crois que c'est que
c'est malheureusement c'est la maladie
du pouvoir alors vous faites aussi
ah oui aussi où j'ai trouvé aussi cette
phrase aussi qui me résume bien ce que
vous avez voulu faire c'est pourquoi
nous raconter ton jamais ce que le
pouvoir fait aux hommes mais seulement
ce que les hommes font du pouvoir
effectivement ça lit vous raconter ce
que le pouvoir fait tout fait aux hommes
mais ce n'est si je peux dire qu'un
aspect du libre pour moi ce qui
m'intéressait parce que j'ai essayé
d'aider c'est ce qui se passe c'est
parce je me disais un conte
philosophique
autrefois on disait ou ceci ou cela
lance direct où les jeunes filles
veulent apprendre qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas tomber amoureuse d'un homme très
ambitieux parce que un jour elles seront
sacrifiés à cette ambition ou un jeune
homme naïf doit savoir qu'il ne faut pas
aller tirer les moustaches des tigres au
pouvoir et je suis très intéressé par
les personnages féminins a notamment eu
un personnage les pousses de caster ça
c'est voulu donner je ne sais pas mais
la médaille d'or de la qualité vous
éludez et manquera vraiment à vous les
avez observé je veux bien sûr d observer
mais par seulement c'est les femmes de
président de la république passé présent
futur des femmes d'hommes politiques en
général c'est l'enfer je ne crois pas
qu'il puisse y avoir de situation du
pénible pour une femme d'être la femme
d'un homme
d'un véritable ambitieux c'est vrai
quelle que soit la nature de l'ambition
il faut pas s'y tromper et pas seulement
les hommes politiques mais c'est pire
avec les hommes vérité vous dites aussi
des deux qu'on peut disputer un homme à
une femme n'est pas la politique ça
surement exemple alors je ne pourrais
pas me permettre de boliden et parce que
je serais très indiscret mais tous ceux
qui ont voté quelques idées là-dessus
qu'il ait fait connaître en tout ils
seront tous c'est ce que je vais dire
cet avis calme